Game of Thrones is back to normal war
game of Thrones means more violent
swordplay more abrupt cuts from
scorching deserts to Arctic snow escapes
and more sex position the HBO show was
adapted from a series of books by george
RR martin or as i like to call him ger
because that's the sound I made when I
think of what he's doing to us girl does
it really take seven books and a zillion
pages of pop when it's been clear since
book 1 chapter 14 that this series is
building to a pitch battle between ice
zombies and fire-breathing dragons cut
to the chase already grrrrrr the pace of
his book releases is slowing from one
every two years to a gap of six years
between books but despite what some of
you geeks are saying I'm okay with that
hey Asimov spent three decades on the
foundation series that is I was okay
with that until my calculation suggested
that the HBO series the best show on
television
except for arrow is going to run out of
material before the saga concludes oh
seven pills no no not okay
if this trend line continues the next
book won't be out until 2018 and the
concluding book won't be out until 2026
even if HBO continues splitting each
book into two seasons worth of episodes
they'll run out of material six years
before the last book appears we may
reach a point where things happen on the
show before they happen in books that's
just wrong clearly HBO will have to slow
things I suggest they dig deeper for
more details Silmarillion style they
could devote an entire episode to
enumerated the 77 dishes served at
Joffrey Baratheon sweating feast or how
about nothing so long refresher course
on the various Royal Signals found in
the land of
I think there's a golden cracking of
house Greyjoy the flayed man of house
all this silver proud of house Tully
what what's happening
hey ru sects positioning over me not
cool
we'll find that if menus and signals are
too boring then the game of thrones TV
show needs to go full-on Swedish soft
ten minutes of pot per episode
followed by 45 minutes of nudity this
series could run or deaf games I'm
skinemax sure but it would be worth it
is george RR martin a master of detail
or a slave to it did we really need to
know all of the ingredients in the
mutton stew let me know what you think
in the comments